c'est le cauchemar de tous les
automobilistes d'immenses nids-de-poule
qui met la suspension de leur véhicule à
rude épreuve des fois il faut les éviter
oui vraiment une course entre ces deux
fichiers là chaque fois il faut toujours
manoeuvrer avec les nids-de-poule
c'est vraiment ce que je regarde plus
par terre que je regarde si certains
réussissent à les éviter parfois
dangereusement
d'autres n'y échappe pas changement goût
de poules avec le gel le redoux des
dernières semaines la pluie deux fois
plus abondante que normalement en saison
hivernale
les conditions météorologiques ont
entraîné une aggravation des
nids-de-poule c'est un identitaire main
exigeant pour nos équipes sur le terrain
on effectivement constaté l'apparition
d'un plus grand nombre de dix poules
l'opération que le matage d'urgence a
repris à la ville de montréal qui assure
en faire une priorité
c'est pas qu'on en fait pas assez au
niveau des infrastructures vous savez
les nippons l'on va venir à bout de sa
sueur d'auge deux fronts alors
rapidement cédé après opération
d'urgence deuxième arme importante pour
la ville de montréal dans sa ville
comptait ni paul soutenir niveau les
infrastructures sur le boulevard de la
vérendrye est un immense cratère
entraîné une série de crevaisons le
garage du coin est débordé
mais après tu es 25 crevaison par jour
dans ces circonstances la ville
recommande d'adapter sa conduite
ralentir
évitez de freiner brusquement rien
toutefois pour calmer la frustration des
montréalais malheureusement habitués s'y
frustra puis c'est même un peu quand je
dirais ont tout parce que la ville de
montréal est reconnue et reconnu pour sa
poursuite poule
et si jacques andré charbonneau radio
canada mon frère